okay you know I haven't gotten into
arguments people who have memory for the
exact turn of phrase that you used like
a week ago I was feeling the pain of
this write off the entire history of you
last episode of the first season of
black mirror so this one is interesting
which that's a lame term for me to open
what they're all interesting so I had to
kind of think on this one a little bit
after watching it usually I shoot these
videos within ten minutes of seeing this
one I had to think on for I don't know
maybe uh almost an hour or so sort of
land and settle and sort of get my read
on it and exactly what it might have
been that it was trying to go for and I
don't mean that in a it was unfocused
way I mean that in a the the layering of
this technology and sort of the roots of
it presume or what I presume to be the
roots of it and the parallels to
technology as it currently exists are a
little bit different from some of the
other things that are going on with it I
think it is to a certain degree
interpretable as to what sort of the
central focus of the thing is that I'm
kind of rambling now okay to sort of get
what I'm talking about when they're when
they're all just kind of sitting around
you know playing back memories and it
brought to mind basically like going
through your old Facebook or Instagram
feed or YouTube videos in my case and
just you know rather than experiencing
anything new you're just revisiting
Andry mixing the stuff you already did
your you're dwelling on the past rather
than really taking in a bunch of new
experiences and anytime something's
going on that you're kind of not into
this I'll just escape back to what
things were once before and like
I'm a sort of I made that connection but
beyond that what I kind of latched on to
and maybe this isn't the same for
everybody it's the fact that I humans
aren't wired with the intention that
they will have perfect recollection and
the fact that we have the ability to to
a certain degree choose how we remember
things is kind of important like to our
our function and our ability to live as
social animals because the minute you
can go back and see to a certainty
exactly what was said with the exact
inflection with you know all of it then
you you then have to deal with that you
and you can pick all of that apart and
there is a validity to choosing to fail
to failing to notice a detail to
choosing to remember it a way that maybe
makes your life easier maybe make
somebody else's life easier and yet at
the same time the way this particular
story is told it's very obvious that
pretty pretty much everybody involved is
not a good person for different reasons
but a kind of across the board and you
know you you have to wonder you know
what what is the point at which we lose
the value of being able to confirm that
you know crack open the secrets that
somebody's keeping is that worth all the
rest of it it seems pretty clear to me
that the that the the lead character
decided no no it wasn't you know Liam as
he's walking through his empty house
replaying what it used to be like when
his wife was still there until he gets
the point where he digs that thing out
and that was when this show does Gore
and just grew some painful moments it
man it lingers on them and like and I
mean I'm not a Gore hound I don't
consider my
either but it's when things linger and
just really let it stretch out and play
out the camera doesn't cut away that's
when I can view I start to score him a
little bit so that had it going on
performances so Toby Kebbell it was nice
to see him in something that's good
where I can see his face because up to
this point the only good things I'd seen
him in he was an ape so but he was good
a he what he wasn't likable it was kind
of a jerk not kind of he was a jerk and
right off the bat as well and then Jodie
Whittaker and I feel like this is this
is the best I've gotten for for getting
a sense of Jodie Whittaker as an actress
because I tried watching broadchurch and
I only got through the first episode it
wasn't bad I wasn't like this is junk
I did it just failed to grab me enough
for me to set aside the time in my
schedule I would have needed to watch
the rest of the thing so I feel like
this is I feel like I'm watching Jodie
Whittaker effectively for almost the
first time because I'm getting to see a
complete story any complete performance
from her now and she does very well and
it's a that I was gonna say there's a
lot of nuance but that it's funny it's
one of those things we're like I almost
want to say you go back and look but I
don't have to say that the episode
doesn't itself actually track back and
look and get you know get a real zeroing
in on her reactions or inflections of
the things she says but in the memories
that Liam is revisiting at the very end
she is exuding that warmth in you you
understand why he's clinging to that and
why he's playing back those memories but
you know we also get the fact that it's
very very obvious that they are not
working and they are very unhappy and
she has the way she has chosen to cope
with that
not exactly okay either but like I said
there's really it's really no good
people in this particular story and it's
funny I was kind of waiting for a twist
and it doesn't really do that it just
lets it play out it lets the realistic
end you know result of people who just
live with this stuff in their head that
it lets them play back stuff and put it
up on a screen for other people to see
it just lets that play out and it
doesn't have a surprise thing or a
sudden revelation it just follows the
The Strand to a dark and oh boy that
would be awful you know kind of place
that said I really like there's a moment
at then the dinner scene early on where
one of the guests explains why she
thinks it's so important to have this
device and part of it was the the way
the line was written but a big part of
it was her performance you you felt that
sense of I couldn't I I couldn't
possibly
and again that's sort of where I made
that connection to social media because
I think you know there are people and
and I don't think I don't think either
one is inherently right or wrong but
there are certainly people out there who
make the choice to more or less unplug
from social media and feel better and
more relaxed more at ease and more
themselves and then there are other
people who you know that's that's the
primary way they connect with some of
the really important people in their
lives that's how they keep track of
their memories and what's gone on and
the idea of not having that of not
having a reliable connection a reliable
record is a scary prospect for some
people and and I don't know who the
actress was who who who delivered that
line but she delivered it with a sense
of heartfelt nough step that I think it
needed because if that hadn't been there
the episode would have kind of run the
risk of well how do we get to the point
where people even do this like
you think about it for more than 30
seconds you'd go boy maybe this isn't a
great idea but or or you think God you
know maybe you'll get in Sabha wouldn't
any everybody like get rid of it after a
while but then you you hear that
argument and as much as you know us as
viewers can think boy I can think of a
million ways that this thing can go
wrong and then we get to see some of
them play out it was nice to have that
sort of very heartfelt argument in favor
of the technology and I think that
helped create a sense of realism to the
world we really odd detail I don't know
if it means anything it just struck me
as odd how old-fashioned the cars were
like with the gear shift up here and
everything like was weird lighting like
they were self-driving but when he
drives himself it's like a 1970s kind of
call was odd and it wasn't just his it's
kind of funky again I don't know if that
means anything but it was a detail I
noticed and if that means something
somebody tell me cuz it's it it's still
sticking in my head oh the other little
detail that the main thing about social
media is that we we get to see and again
it's not lingered on it's not a twist
and it's not like where the story's
going but it's a moment that happens we
see very clearly that their baby has
this thing in its head wasn't give it a
choice it just got put in and you know
again linking it back to social media
there are parents that basically set up
social media accounts for their kids
even if their babies that you know with
the intention that when they grow up
old enough they'll they'll actually take
it over themselves but they'll be all
this backlog of memories and pictures
and from when you are baby it's like on
the one hand it's like oh that's that's
kind of nice we've got the record and
everything on the other hand it's like
you're not you're not give me giving
them a choice and it's it's a funny
thing to think about because it's
something that that seems innocuous but
you think about it for a little bit and
it's like that maybe that's
weird maybe that's odd that's a little
sinister and again again just little
details like that and it was just
interesting to see how this technology
played out putting additional strain or
not additional strain making the strain
of a relationship manifest because the
the technology certainly didn't create
the problem the problem are is these
people the problem is this relationship
this relationship isn't working the
technology isn't helping the situation
and it's facilitating the damage but
it's not the cause of it so it was
really interesting to see that play out
I think that be said for the first
season which is only three episodes and
they're all good it's probably my least
favorite or the first season I I think
I'm gonna get 15 million merits the top
spot with the national anthem just
squeak iam behind it it's like a really
close call between those two and the
entire history of you is good it's
certainly very good but I out of these
three that I comfortable you can put
that one at the bottom and then it's
really close but I think I gotta put 15
mil 15 million merits ahead of it I'm
not I'm not in the mindset where I'm up
for comparing these to the episodes of
Stevens and for that I've seen but I
figured it was worth ranking them within
the season itself so that is that's it
for season 1 of black mirrors so in a
week I'll start working on season 2 so
the entire history of you Oh last detail
I love the the effect on the eyes when
they're playing that stuff back is
vaguely creepy and that was a good touch
so what were your thoughts on this thing
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it do all
the stuff with likes and subscribes and
Twitter followers and patient support
maybe just check out the page see if
it's worth your money you know it's a
thought links for all that stuff is down
below so
till next time this council is a German
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]